je serai très favorable à se dire que
100 % des émissions du secteur aérien
qui peuvent être compensées sont
compensées est ce qu'on ne peut pas
faire de plus eh bien on ne le fait pas
on en arrive toujours dans la même
situation de retour à la radicalité à la
racine c'est on ne fait pas avec du
kérosène qu'on n'arrive pas à produire
autrement ou qu'on n'arrive pas à
compenser ensuite je suis assez d'accord
sur ce qui a été dit notamment sur les
besoins
c'est vrai que certaines personnes ont
un besoin de voyager mais c'est pas le
cas de la majorité du monde et
d'ailleurs c'est sans doute pour ça que
ce terme de besoin et l'idée a introduit
donc si on considère qu' il ya des vols
nécessaires et d'autres qui ne sont pas
eh bien il faut se poser la question de
qu'est ce qu'un vol nécessaires et
caisses comment on fait pour réduire les
vols qu'ils ne sont pas on a parlé de
quotas les quotas ils sont pas forcément
sur les individus il pourrait aussi être
sur les trajets ou sur les compagnies ou
sur les aéroports
donc on pourra voir tout un système qui
permet de réduire ça ne fait pas le
choix à la place du consommateur ont
réduit le nombre de tickets possible et
ensuite libre à la société de
s'organiser pour savoir qui c'est qui
les prend et après je voulais terminer
sur un dernier point qui est l'histoire
du confinement
pour moi la viande c'est un système de
confinement c'est un système de
cloisonnement dans un avion et tout ce
qui est plus confinés et quand on fait
quand on quand on consomme de l'avion en
fait on ne voyage pas on n'a pas de
plaisir de voyager on n'a pas de grand
large avec l'avion en fait on consomme
un déplacement rapide pour aller
ailleurs
[Musique]